on the heels of calling roughly half the
country semi-fascist the biden
administration is now somehow
upping the rhetoric referring to us all
as a quote
extreme threat to democracy
the president thinks that there is an
extremist threat to our democracy
the president has been clear as he can
be on that particular
piece when we talk about a democracy
when we talk about our freedoms
the way that he sees as the mag of
republicans are the most energized part
of the republican party
that extreme this is an extreme threat
to our democracy to our freedom uh to
our rights
notice that line was not off the cuff
that was not merely some gaff from
corrine jean-pierre or joe biden
she was reading off of her written notes
she repeated the phrase
the white house made a conscious
decision to refer to magga republicans
the same way that they would refer to
isis actually probably more harshly than
they would refer to isis the lib is
called the leader of isis an austere
religious scholar the libs hand
afghanistan over to the taliban okay
they're actually pretty nice to the
terrorists and to isis and al qaeda and
all those people
they reserve the terrorist rhetoric
for you
for parents and for conservatives and
for mega republicans which by the way
just means republicans
that's it that's all there is the never
trump movement at this point is pretty
much just bill crystal and five or six
people that he has over to complain
about donald trump over t okay
statistically for all intents and
purposes mega republicans just means
republicans
which means the president of the united
states
the same president who keeps threatening
to strafe us all with squadrons of f-15s
is saying that half of the country
should be treated
as terrorists he's saying that the only
way we can have government of the people
by the people and for the people is if
we get rid of half the people
a bad idea in general
an especially bad idea when those half
of the people
are you i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from toby who says
i didn't want to believe that michael
actually loves pumpkin spice lattes but
when he started calling them psls so
casually i knew he was being honest
now i need to find a way to reconcile
this with the cigar smoking only y
chromosome image of michael that i had
before i'll reconcile it for you i know
that this can be shocking this was
explained to me a little bit when i was
in college by a pal of mine he was a few
years older who's very very preppy
and i said you know he'd wear pink polo
shirts all the time and i said hey man
i won't use his name but i said hey man
isn't it a little girly to wear pink
polo shirts and isn't it a little fopish
and effeminate and he told me he said
michael
you don't understand it it's actually
the manliest thing of all to wear a pink
polo shirt
because
you see the the pink polo shirt it is
just a facade it is in a way a kind of
like a girdle or a corset to constrain
the virile manliness within just aching
to get out that's what the pumpkin spice
latte is okay it is just it is a a
veneer of civilization
okay of of a sort of
nice light okay this is a but
but beneath
the surface just underneath that frothy
little foam and tasty little pumpkin
spice
sauce on top oh there's it's just pure
masculinity toxic waiting to explode
that's what's going on with my psls and
and
one of those things that i can do when
i'm really unleashing my masculinity
would be to work on my car when i want
to work on my car what do i do i go to
rockauto.com right now head on over to
rockauto.com write knowles in their how
did you hear about this box nobody likes
to spend money on their cars if you buy
it you want to drive it you want it to
run forever maintenance-free
unfortunately
that's not the way that things work cars
require upkeep the good news is you can
maintain your car for less when you shop
for auto parts at rockauto.com
chain stores have different price tiers
for pros you know the actual
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers rockauto.com's prices
are the same for everybody they are
reliably low no gimmicks they will not
change prices based on what the market
will bear or some you know twenty
percent off at three a.m on a tuesday no
none of that their prices make it
affordable for customers to keep their
daily drives and classics safely on the
road rockauto.com has been in the auto
parts business for 20 years family owned
more importantly they've been with this
show for what five six years now pretty
much right from the beginning right now
go to rockauto.com get the brakes shocks
carpet wipers headlights mirrors
mufflers lug nuts or any other part you
need rockauto.com
write knolls in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
speaking of the maga republicans
we need to add another coin to the
donald trump was right jar
this i always try to
keep the receipts here you know because
here's what happens in politics
a conservative says something
the liberals say that's crazy that's
stupid you're an idiot you don't know
anything that's wrong that's dangerous
it's a horrible idea and
then i don't know call it six months
later sometimes even a couple of years
later the conservative is proven
completely correct and we say hey we
were right the whole time and then what
did the lib say no never mind what are
you talking about who remembers that now
forget about it move along move along
and rinse and repeat that goes on and on
and on then the conservatives will
observe something and they'll say wait
hold on no this is what i think the
let's say no you're completely wrong
it's stupid they'll laugh at us they'll
ridicule us well this is what's
happening right now
when it comes to energy
you might recall a few years ago donald
trump
warned that europe's energy policy right
now was making europe and germany in
particular extremely reliant on russia
to heat the homes and power the cars and
keep germany going and at the time
all the libs and germany in particular
mocked donald trump for this observation
this was considered so risible that the
the the american left-wing news outlets
put out joke compilations of trump
making this claim this is a clip from
now this which is a
left-wing
news source and commentary source
mocking is from the time mocking trump's
suggestion
germany's reaction to trump's inaccurate
claim is priceless become totally
dependent
on russian energy
if it does not immediately change course
no they're laughing look at that look at
those germans they're laughing oh is
that idiot trump trump's claim is not
accurate and highly misleading cnbc says
germany imports only a fraction of its
total energy from russia
we are committed to maintaining our
independence
from the encroachment
of expansionist foreign powers
now this
there it is
okay so how's that shaping up well
russia just announced that it's going to
cut off germany's gas supply
via the nordstream one pipeline for
three days just three days okay well
that shouldn't matter at all right
nothing's going to happen because
trump's a big dumb stupid idiot right
and he said that germany is too reliant
on russian energy and all the germans
left okay
okay so who cares they're gonna shut off
this one pipeline for three days no big
deal right well here's what the german
economy minister robert habeck told the
financial times apparently this this
move by russia to shut off the gas for
just three days has already forced
german companies to stop production
it's a development that he said is
alarming he said quote it's not good
news because it can mean that the
industries in question aren't just being
restructured but are experiencing a
rupture a structural rupture one that is
happening under enormous pressure
oh
not laughing now i guess
the germans have said what can we do
with the three-day pause they said i
assume that we will be able to cope with
it that was klaus mueller the president
of germany's network regulator as we
told reuters i trust that russia will
return to 20 on saturday but no one can
really say oh so it sounds like trump
was
100 correct
and all the germans were laughing and
all the news outlets called trump a big
stupid dumb idiot and all the
conservatives who followed trump were
just stupid idiot rubes who don't know
anything about energy except
we were all completely right
and all of the geniuses at msnbc and the
financial analysts and the establishment
and the things they were all completely
wrong
that's what happened
and it's very important to point this
out because it keeps happening that's
why i keep focusing on this when it
comes to covid
we were right about the masks all of the
genius
authorities and experts and fouchy and
all the big tech censors and all of the
all of the petty government officials
from the local level to the
international level
they were they were wrong we were right
about the masks all of them were wrong
about the masks except for fouchy
briefly when he was being honest about
the masks but then he reversed his
position how about the vaccines when we
said i don't think the vaccines are
actually going to stop you from catching
covet or spreading it and then
everyone all the experts all the
authorities said the opposite and they
all called us a bunch of big dumb stupid
idiots and science deniers and all the
rest we were 100 percent right they were
100 wrong
same thi catching cover transmitting
covet the the risks of the vaccines
initially we were told there were no
risks to the vaccines we said i think
there actually are probably some some
pretty serious risks we were 100 right
they were 100 wrong and it's not it
wasn't just covet that this is the fa
the case on it's it's everything
it's everything from the covid masks to
the russian and german energy sectors
our experts are established geniuses who
have the power to
form public opinion and exclude certain
opinions
they don't know anything okay and joe
shmoe on the street and joshua's
representative named donald trump
are much much more correct they have a
much much better record than these
people do
speaking of extreme threats
there is a trailer out for a movie
that in spite of myself i cannot wait to
see but it's very very disturbing the
movie is called
winnie the pooh
blood and honey
you know you're the first person i ever
shown this place to and why am i so
special because soon will be christopher
and mary robin
you should be close to this
christopher robin from winnie the pooh
is all grown up
they go back to the 100 acre wood
we were friends for many years and
they're out
the
there
childhood characters christopher
we need to leave
now i really need to find out what's
happening here okay
have been abandoned by christopher robin
and have turned wild and then there's
demented winnie the pooh starts stabbing
people
okay
it goes on i think there was piglet
there it's like attacking people uh this
is seems really really stupid and funny
and i'll i'll probably go see it part of
the reason this movie can be made is the
copyright has run out on winnie the pooh
so now people can use the intellectual
property
but there is something
disturbing here and it's not just the
fact that you got these demented
characters slashing people there have
been teen slashers for a long time in
movies what makes this especially
disturbing is it's a beloved childhood
character a character that made you feel
really safe and nice and warm is now
coming back and killing you why because
christopher robin abandoned him right
abandoned him and now the animals have
turned demented what the movie i think
is really about certainly from the
trailer what it seems is it's a movie
about a permanent loss of innocence
what what the movie is really i don't
think i'm reading too deeply into a teen
slasher what it's really about
the crux of the whole movie why they
make it all about winnie the pooh is
it's because it is about
people who have lost their childhood and
their childhood innocence who who don't
know how to get it back anymore in
society and that that actually is a
cultural shift when we want to talk to
each other about how scary this movie is
you've got to check out pure talk usa
right now head over to puretalk.com
enter promo code knowles podcast verizon
att t-mobile these guys take way too
much of your money every month and the
way they justify it is by giving you way
more data than you will ever really need
that's really concerning especially
given the state of our current economy
no matter what the libs tell you we are
in a recession now it's time to hunker
down save some money wherever you can
one of the easiest ways that you can do
that is by looking at your current cell
phone bill are you paying too much money
what's your current bill could be 80
bucks 90 bucks are you paying for way
more data than you need then you should
talk to my friends over at puretalk
puretalk gives you myriad choices so
that you can choose the data plan that
is right for you whether that's two gigs
per month or an unlimited plan with a
mobile hotspot doesn't matter whatever
you want by switching to puretalk the
average family of four is saving over 75
bucks per month
customers are realizing they simply do
not need as much data as they thought
plus puretalk makes it easy to find the
right plan for you and your family
they're a veteran-owned company with
customer service team right here in the
united states
make the switch okay it's super easy to
do it takes 10 minutes i am a pure talk
customer i love it fabulous 5g wireless
network right now this month when you
switch to puretalk you pay for one month
you get the second month free i have
been endorsing pure talk for an
extremely long time right now they have
never made an offer this big go to
puretalk.com choose your plan enter
promo code knowles podcast for this
special offer that is puretalk.com code
knowles podcast to get your second month
free
i am going to go see winnie the pooh
blood and honey
but
i want to see it as much because it's a
it looks like a kind of fun silly
slasher movie as for what it means
culturally i get letters to the mail bag
all the time and i got one last week and
it really stuck with me the question was
michael i you know i got really into
porn and all sorts of a lot of questions
are about porn but it could be about the
anything that causes you to lose your
innocence and he says i feel i really
miss my innocence
i want it but i don't know that i can
get my innocence back
and i think that's what this movie is
about
and part of growing up is losing
a little bit of your
innocence
and
now we hope that we don't just
constantly degrade ourselves we hope
that
you know we don't
remain mired in all the problems that
come along with youth and all of the
temptations
but how do you get how do you recover
some of that well you've got to
got to get back on the right road again
okay and that doesn't it doesn't mean
just remain in perpetual adolescence i
think that's something that millennials
and gen z but millennials in particular
have really fallen into millennials
don't want to grow up millennials every
time they pay a bill
they they post it on instagram and they
say well i'm totally adulting wow isn't
this shock no it's it shouldn't be
shocking that someone in their 30s is
doing things that adults do
but millennials don't want to grow up
they don't want to get married they
don't want to have kids they don't want
to get off their parents cell phone plan
these are people who are in their 30s
and early 40s in some cases but they
don't want to do it they're stuck in
perpetual adolescence
and so how they they they want to go
back to disneyland alone they don't even
have kids yet they'll just go to disney
world they'll just go they'll go watch
the latest
superhero movie but they'll go and i
don't mean to knock people for you know
having a little bit of nostalgia for
their childhood
but you're supposed to do those
things while growing up and and with
your kids that's how you get to relive
your childhood when you when you're an
adult you get to do it
through and with your own children
actually kenny loggins wrote a whole
song about this specifically about
winnie the pooh it's called back to poo
corner and the whole thing is he wrote
it when he was a high school junior or
senior and the whole thing was wow i've
wandered away i can't get back to the
hundred acre wood i want where's come on
i gotta get back to winnie the pooh and
all my friends so help me if you can
i've got to get back to the place at
pooh corner and he realizes he can't
because his childhood is over and he's
growing up now and he's graduating high
school and he revisits that song later
and he says you know i'm looking i'm
paraphrasing the lyrics but he says i
was looking at my little kid lying in
his crib and i realized now i've
returned
to the hundred acre wood in poo corner
and winnie the pooh and i've returned as
the dad now and i get and my little kid
is there hugging my little winnie the
pooh doll and so i do get to you know
return in some ways to the joys of
childhood but it's in a new way it's in
a mature way and an elevated way and our
culture has kind of stopped that we've
kind of stopped having kids we've kind
of stopped growing up we've got to stop
doing the things that adults are
supposed to do
i promise you that will be the most
detailed analysis of winnie the pooh
blood and honey trailer that you will
see anywhere but i do think that's
what's undergirding the movie i'll see
it anyway but i'll see it in the same
way that i look at a car accident around
our culture and say gosh we've gotten
really really decadent and weird haven't
we
speaking of child abuse
doctors now
lib doctors and teachers are getting
really brazen about admitting that they
are not only violating social norms but
violating the law in some cases there's
a doctor right now
in san francisco dr scott moser
who is admitting
that he
tr not only trans as the kids but he
trans as little kids he trans his kids
without any minimum age to perform these
kind of surgeries at all
the gcc gender confirmation center in
san francisco we kind of have these like
secret missions now now that it's on a
slide these public secret missions which
are
one of them is that we try to we try to
live with our values 30 to 40 years in
the future so and that puts us in a
mindset of
extreme affirmation because affirmation
at that time is a foregone conclusion
this is a time in the future when gender
is just a thing nobody makes a big deal
out of it people are being screened as
children and adolescents for their
gender journey and appropriate steps are
taken to get them involved in a
multidisciplinary process to get them
where they need to go that's that's the
future
i do not have a minimum age of any sort
in my practice there's no chronological
age that says you don't get surgery now
having said that i don't think i've ever
done a consult on a 12 year old yet but
we would if one came our way we just
haven't had reason to um and then we've
done a number of 13 year olds who are
who we did consults on i think i've done
one or two 13 year old surgeries
i think i've done one or two 13 year old
surgery he's lopped off the genitals of
13 year olds
as as i say every time one of these
stories comes out
we are accelerating down the slippery
slope it's not that we've reached the
bottom it's not that we're going to keep
going afterward we're accelerating how
fast we're going down the slippery slope
ten years ago the idea that there would
be more than a handful of adults who had
these mutilations would be a scandal and
unthinkable
the idea that someone who was 18 years
old or younger would have this done
truly truly beyond the realm of the
imagination
then the idea even a couple of years ago
that this would happen to 16 year olds
unthinkable
yesterday the idea that this would
happen to 13 year olds or 12 year olds
he said i'd do it to a 12 year old i
haven't yet but i would
would be unthinkable
what's it going to be tomorrow tomorrow
it's going to be nine the day after that
it's going to be eight six seven
there's he says no limit
and of course
the logic
or the kind of logic the kind of illogic
but it follows from the premises is on
his side and conservatives need to wise
up on this
the minute that we grant the premise
that a man who thinks he's a woman maybe
we should call him a she
the minute that we grant in any way the
premise that
the man who thinks he's a woman should
maybe be able to use the girls bathroom
the minute we grant the premise that
an adult should have the right to lop
off his own genitals and pretend to be a
woman
an adult 35 years old i mean these days
that's not an adult because they don't
know how to do adulting because
millennials don't want to grow up but
let's say someone chronologically an
adult the minute we grant the premise
that anyone at any age should be able to
lop off his genitals because he's really
seriously a man in a woman's body or
he's got this permanent psychological
condition where he's a man in a woman's
body and so we have to let him lock his
genitals off
at the minute we grant that
we've given the libs the whole game
because if that's really true
then certainly it's much better for
people who have this totally real
illness you know where you're a man in a
woman's body or whatever
uh we have to let them do it before
puberty because puberty is only going to
set in the dysphoria and then they're
going to be really really sad and
depressed and have all these problems so
we have to do it
in fact we should encourage people to
have it done before they're 13.
probably before they're nine people are
starting puberty earlier and earlier
because of all the weird chemicals we're
pumping into the food so okay let's do
it at nine now
you have to grant that premise i think
or you you have to go to that extreme if
you grant the premise of the libs that's
why we're going there and and
conservatives and especially
libertarians are always trying to split
the baby on this well no okay it's
insane if you're under 18 but it's
totally fine if you're over 18. we have
to no
no it's just
we've got if we're gonna have a society
we have to agree on some basic
principles of reality
can men become women or not
they can't
okay so then no one
should be able to do that
especially the kids but really no one
speaking of abuse
christine who is the republican governor
of south dakota
she just went on fox and friends
talk about trying to split the baby to
uh to discuss the fbi's raid on
mar-a-lago
which now it's so preposterous the fbi
has posted on social media a photograph
of the alleged top secret documents that
trump had the classified documents that
he totally wasn't allowed to have i
guess maybe sort of and they're so super
duper top secret that they had to raid
his home
in in you know
without any warning whatsoever as he's
preparing to run for president 2024 so
super duper top secret
that we're going to post a picture of
them
on social media so christy gnome
republican governor goes on fox and
friends
and i got to tell you this whole
interview i felt like i was in bizarro
world this was not it was not an
interview on msnbc it was not an
interview on cnn it was an interview on
on fox news it's supposed to be the
right wing channel
about how
how terrible it was that trump had the
documents
he had apparently three classified
documents in his desk and then the stuff
as brian detailed on the floor it shows
uh five yellow folders marked top secret
and another one with that says secret
sci which means sensitive
compartmentalized information
those are the biggest secrets in the
world
why would he and apparently the
president former president went through
him in january why wouldn't he say oh
you know what i really need to turn that
back over why'd he have all that stuff
at mar-a-lago
well that's why i think it's important
that this is transparent and that we do
have someone who's outside of the doj
looking at this and talking to people
what what is this information we don't
know what was in there we don't know if
i think believe president trump
declassified all this information let's
find out really what the process is what
is right what's precedent that other
other presidents have followed and make
sure that this is
governor i don't think any president has
ever carted off that many documents to
their house after they left the
presidency
i guess i guess what this comes from
is just
we disagree on the premise here
because you've got steve ducey's really
hammering this home he had classified
documents you're not allowed to have
classified documents and christie gnome
is
uh she seems kind of surprised by the
commentary too and said well you know
this will play out whatever
they weren't classified
the documents were not classified you
know how i know with 100 certainty that
the documents were not classified
because trump said so
and that's
actually all it takes that's all it
takes is for the president to say the
documents were not classified that
declassifies them because he's saying i
declassified them in the past now you
might respond and say well who knows if
trump actually declassified them in the
past
the answer to that
only donald trump can know that for sure
but the documents still had a top secret
classified stamp on them yeah okay fine
doesn't matter it does i guess people
just don't
we've never been in a situation where
the fbi has knocked down the doors of a
former president and
he even raised an objection to a
president doing this sort of thing
but
the president does not need a special
stamp to declassify the documents he
doesn't need to go through a process he
doesn't need to ask permission of some
deputy director of whatever the hell at
the doj he just
if the president said if if a former
president says these documents were not
classified or
were declassified at some point by me
they just
they just are that's it it's no it's
completely
made up
okay it's like if you begin with the
false premise
then you can end at the crazy logical
conclusion of that
that's what the libs do but the premise
is just wrong if a man can really be a
woman then you end up at transiting the
kids but a man can't be a woman if
donald trump
can have mishandled the classified
documents then you end up at this place
where maybe he committed a crime but he
can't it's not it's ontologically not
possible for the president to do that if
my aunt had testicles she would be
my uncle
speaking of the biden administration
the biden administration is pointing at
trump right now
and trying raiding his home and calling
half the country fascists and doing
whatever distractions they can because
of their completely failed record we
know that they have a failed record on
the economy we know they have a failed
record on immigration we know they have
an extremely failed record on foreign
policy we know they got a failed record
on energy we know the list goes on and
on one area we haven't talked enough
about they have a really failed record
on drugs
the american life expectancy decreased
again
okay it should not be decreasing it's
supposed to be increasing because of all
that progress that we've allegedly got
going on but it's decreasing and it's
decreasing in large part because of
deaths of despair specifically deaths
caused by drug overdoses so
at the
white house briefing karine jean-pierre
has asked hey what is the president
doing about drug overdoses
here's her answer
there's a big problem now that rainbow
fentanyl which is designed to target
children
has been found in 18 states what
specifically is the president doing
about this so uh we just talked about uh
the day the overdose awareness day that
that we are
observing today
i just laid out
what the second gentleman
and others are doing
within this administration
and
you know we are going to continue to
focus
on the
the steps that we're taking that we have
taken you have the 80 million dollars
that dhs just announced today on drug
prevention and the president has taken
many steps he's made this a priority
so the only answer they said we're going
to spend 80 million dollars
on this vague thing she doesn't say what
the 80 million dollars is and then the
only concrete
action that corrine jean-pierre can say
the biden administration is doing on
this once in an ever
historic
drug overdose problem is
well we're observing
drug overdose awareness day
what are you
what are you peter ducey are you crazy
what do you mean we're not doing
anything we're it's it's overdose
awareness day you know we're all wearing
a little pin
you know we we posted a hashtag we did a
hashtag
and so yeah we're not
we're not doing anything about you know
the completely open border that all the
drugs are crossing from
or crossing through we're not doing
anything about big pharma
that the rest of the drugs are coming
from we're not doing anything about the
mass nationwide legalization campaign
that our own party is pushing
we're not doing anything about the
the criminal justice reform so-called
that's letting all the drug peddlers out
of prison
we're not
but it's awareness we're we're raising
awareness
no yeah you're the way that the white
house is raising awareness about drug
overdoses is by causing them that's
that's what's raising awareness of it
that's not that awareness and a buck 50
used to get your cup of coffee now you'd
need probably like 550 in addition to
that to the awareness to get a cup of
coffee because of bite inflation
that's you need to do stuff to stop it
and the the democrats are not doing that
they're actually encouraging the drug
problem and unfortunately a lot of
republicans are too
i listened to it was probably
some of the stupidest political
commentary i'd heard in a long time it
came out a few days ago charlemagne the
god is a left-wing
broadcaster and he had this idea for joe
biden which is that
politically it was actually probably a
pretty smart idea as a matter of policy
and the common good and the flourishing
of america it was a really terrible idea
he says what biden should do right now
is just pardon every single person who
is in prison
for the devil's lettuce
i thought it was incredibly
disrespectful
for
joe biden to come out and say the
sentence that britney griner received in
russia was unacceptable it's like yo we
live in a country where
right now if joe biden wanted to
don't need no votes no nothing he could
literally pardon every single person
that is federally
jailed for a non-violent weed offense
he could pardon every single bite it's
my doing life in jail for an ounce and a
half of marijuana right now my whole
point is man when you live in a country
where more more than half of the country
has legalized weed in some way shape or
form whether it's from additional
whether it's for recreational to have
people still locked up for marijuana in
america is ridiculous if i'm joe biden
you need this for the midterms bro
okay yeah i'm pardoning every single
body that's locked up federally for a
non-violent marijuana offense let them
all out
so first of all i think that's going to
be the title of my next blank book
that's my next magnum opus is everybody
who's locked up in federal prison for a
marijuana possession offense
a comprehensive guide because it's
nobody it's nobody it's not real that's
fake okay i gave a long speech on this a
few some months ago six months eight
months ago called america's under
incarceration problem
it's i forget the exact statistic it's
virtually no one and usually even the
people who are on the books in federal
prison for
marijuana possession it's all plea deals
it's all people who are peddlers who are
pushing harder stuff or who had more
than just simple possession and they
pled it down and then they go to the
clink for a little bit but it it
virtually never happens okay but second
of all
for the people on the right the
republicans and the conservatives who
are into legalizing the haitian oregano
and the california cumin and the
peruvian parsley and all the rest of it
i just have to ask you a basic political
question
do you think that that guy is right
about politics that guy mr charlemagne
over there do you think that that
pod head
yes man that was sitting next to him on
the podcast do you think that guy gets
it you think he's on the right side of
politics on forget about pot for a
second just of all the political issues
no do you think the people who are
pushing to let the drug dealers out of
prison
and who are pushing to
you know legalize pot and put it in
every everybody's you know
food
put it in legalize it in cafes and
you're probably going to end up with it
in your breakfast cereal do you think um
forget pot for a second that those guys
who are really into legalizing pot
what where do they stand on
abortion on
uh economic policy on immigration
on
marriage on transgenderism on on every
on foreign policy on every single
political issue where do they stand my
guess is
they are
on the wrong side of every single
political issue
and yet i know there is a group of right
wingers who for some reason have
convinced themselves
that on this one issue they're right
they're not they're not okay don't let
the wool be pulled over your eyes my
friend speaking of
us versus them kind of politics before
we get to the mailbag i've got to get to
this this clip really shocking came out
from project veritas a connecticut
public schools assistant principal
was caught on camera discriminating
against hiring catholics because he says
that if you hire catholics then they're
not going to indoctrinate the kids well
enough and they're not going to churn
out democrat voters in the future
if you find out someone is catholic
i think the questions that myself
included
wow
i'm not allowed to do that but i
i can't
tell them i'm not interviewing you
because you're older i just don't get to
sometimes
set your ways more conservative
it doesn't matter what they think about
you know if they think about it in a
logical way
like
so you kind of like do it on top in a
more liberal
hopefully the way progressive teachers
are actually more savvy
about delivering a democratic message
really
politics we want people that are going
to listen to the people
who listen to the people
it wasn't the conservatives on the
supreme court
so it's
little things like that you hope those
little things stick and then later down
the line you're gonna vote
and
that's it that's what they're going to
do he's saying we don't hire catholics
if someone is a really well-formed
catholic
they're never going to go with the libs
they can't they're not going to do it
too much thomas aquinas that's not
they're not so we can't hire them we got
to discriminate against them how are we
going to do that legally we'll ask them
about transgenderism because they know
this is why the lib's one of the reasons
the libs focus so much on transgenderism
because it just tells you everything if
you believe that men can secretly be
women you're a leftist
if you don't believe that you're one of
the bad people you might even be a
catholic but you're certainly you're one
of those bad conservatives you're out if
you're a little bit older you might be
more conservative okay we're not going
to hire you we don't even need to
mention explicit politics we are going
to push this stuff on kids and churn out
democrat voters starting in
kindergarten and you know to this guy's
in this guy's defense
he's acknowledging one basic truth there
is no neutrality here especially in
education there's no neutrality they're
either going to be trained in the
conservative way
or in the leftist way they're going to
be trained in the atheist way or the
christian way the cat the catholic way
maybe is that's what he's really worried
about
it's going to be some kind of training
that's what education is and so yeah
it's illegal for him to do what he's
doing to discriminate against catholics
and conservatives in in the schools
but he's just he's doing a natural thing
he's saying we want a certain type of
education not another type of education
that's maybe conservatives need to start
thinking that way too i talk a lot on
this show about the squishes you know
the adam kinzinger's
the future former congress lady liz
cheney
whose gelatinous
gop spines
they just
fall apart
under the slightest pressure
it's the kind of pressure kind of
behavior rather that you would never
dream of engaging in or modeling to your
son or daughter and yet
and yet
the numbers are in most of you squished
this very morning you did you might not
have even known it some of you are
squishing right now well michael don't
be so mean to me what are you talking
about it's not hey look it's not me
if you are still
not shaving with a jeremy's razor if you
are still using a razor made by a
company that says that you're toxic
you are one shaming yourself and two
funding the radical gender ideologues
who wish that you would just disappear
down a drain along with that unwanted
stubble don't squish on your values
switch to jeremy's razors and get your
founders series shave kit today go to
jeremysrazors.com
jeremysrazors.com
now finally we have gotten to my
favorite time of the week
when i get to hear from you in the
mailbag the mailbag is sponsored by
puretalk puretalk.com select a plan
enter promo code knowles podcast to get
your second month for free let's take it
away with the voicemail bag
hi mr knowles i'm a 16 year old high
school student in florida who is
fortunate enough to be blessed with the
governorship of ron de santos but
putting that aside i'm taking an ap
environmental studies class this year
and i'm doing that for the purpose of
getting my gpa up and my grades etc
but the consequence of taking an ap
environmental classes i fundamentally
disagree with a lot of the stuff the
teacher says about stuff like global
warming and climate change and etc and i
don't want to just debate teacher class
or anything or sacrifice my grades but i
also don't want to just sit idly by as i
hear what i fundamentally disagree with
so what do you think i should do in this
situation
really great question and i love that
little caveat you said look i'm not
there to debate the teacher
and that's true you're you're actually
not there to debate the teacher
when you sign up for a course you are
there to learn something
and so you should learn whatever you can
you can learn things from very flawed
people you can learn things from very
ignorant people
you can you can learn something from
just about anybody there's a kind of old
expression about this every man is my
teacher i can learn something from him
so learn what you can
when the teacher starts spouting
nonsense
okay you're not going to learn much from
that
tune that out
now if the teacher calls on you says
what do you think about this or asks you
to write a paper
or
starts interrogating you in class then
and this is important
then you speak up and you say what you
really think i am not of the opinion
that you should lie
or hide your views or pretend to be a
different person just to get a decent
grade in the ap course and then you'll
go to college and then well then you'll
have to hide your views and lie about
them and squish too but then that the
only reason you'll do that is because
then you'll get a good job and then when
you get a good job that's when you'll oh
well you'll probably have to squish i
mean you're going to be a first year at
your new job and so you're not going to
want to offend the upper management but
it's okay once you move up maybe you're
in middle management then you can well
you're going to have to squish too it's
not your job to have opinions you know
and you don't want to contradict the
bosses ruffle any feathers but that's
okay maybe someday you'll become the ceo
of the company and then you're gonna
well you probably can't say your opinion
then either by golly you have
responsibilities maybe to your
shareholders maybe to your investors you
got to do what's best for the company
you can't oh and then you're going to
die and then you'll have never had
integrity at all
so i'm not of that opinion
but you need to be wise as a serpent
innocent as a dove you need
to express your views and stand by your
views but you don't need to be
flamboyant about it okay you don't need
to wear the maga hat to ap environmental
studies class every single day
next question
greetings exalted nostradamus peace be
upon you
i have a question for you about acting
i've been acting in theater for about
eight years now and i've recently
secured an agent to pursue acting
professionally
however i have some concerns about the
increasingly profane
and obscene and sexual content that you
see in tv and movies these days
and that i may be expected to do or say
things for the camera or on stage that
directly contradict my morals
so i was wondering if if there is any
gray area regarding what you do as an
actor morally speaking because since i'm
only pretending
is it possible to do or say sinful
things while remaining inculpable
because my heart is
in the right place and my intention is
merely to entertain the audience
basically my question is jim caviezel or
mark wahlberg thank you
this is such a good question and i was
just discussing this last night with the
clavins spencer clavin and drew clavin
and
you know spencer and i met we probably
met for the very first time when we were
doing plays and operas and things in
college so
you know we've been thinking about this
question for a long time and i think
it's like
the iq bell curve meme
okay
at the really dumb stupid idiot drooling
end of the spectrum you guys gonna say
duh i don't know actors are kind of
liars and they're doing bad stuff and
that's bad right and then you get into
the middle of the iq bell curve meme and
they say no actually when you're acting
a role it's completely divorced from
your own person and you have no
culpability whatsoever for the things
you're thinking and doing come on it
plays a play and then at the highest end
of the iq bell curve meme i think you go
back to the drooling guy and i think you
say no actually actors are kind you know
there's a reason they weren't allowed in
restaurants for a lot of history there's
a reason they were lumped together with
criminals and prostitutes for most of
history there's a reason that the church
took a pretty hard line against acting
as a profession
and the theater broadly for you know
roughly
14 to 1600 years
because
it is a complicated question
and it's a little bit different when you
are a writer
and you write a a story about
i don't know a rape and a murder and uh
terrorism and a serial killer
you are your mind is wandering in
certain places you are sometimes opening
up wounds you're sometimes indulging
kind of disordered thoughts and even
desires and then you put it on paper and
that's that it's an action only of the
mind
when you are
attending a play or watching a movie
you are allowing yourself to indulge
certain desires
and things that could be disordered and
not great for your soul but again it is
just in the mind it's not really in the
body when you are acting uniquely when
you are acting you are putting all of
this into your body
and so you are really doing it and
because we're incarnate creatures that
affects us this is especially true
after what is colloquially referred to
as method acting comes about
which is all comes out of freud you have
freud
come about you have the kind of
psychological revolution of the
19th century late 19th century and early
20th century then in russia you have the
stanislavski system which is the first
kind of method acting where where
stanislavski the director of the moscow
art theater says we're no longer going
to have representational stilted acting
where you just you're basically like a
glorified mime no you're going to
develop the inner life of your character
and you're going to live truthfully in
imaginary circumstances out of that then
in new york you get the group theater
the group theater is
people like lee strasberg stella adler
sanford meisner udahog and all these
people and they're all a bunch of
communists and they're all really into
this stuff where your your
inner life is it's all coming from the
subconscious and they all get kind of
they all do a lot of weird stuff lee
strasberg
one of the great acting teachers in new
york won't name him uh but he refer he
referred to lee strasberg as a pervert
and a voyeur and a lot of it you know
when people really get into the method
or any of this
the meisner technique or the adler
technique sometimes it really can mess
you up okay
actors are all completely insane and it
it really can warp your
soul and your body so i'm not going to
give you the easy answer of hey don't
worry about it it's okay you know no big
deal a place to play no you have to be
very careful about it because it is your
mind and it is your soul and it is your
body next question
hi michael big fan of the show
uh i think that too often the left gains
ground by defining the parameters by
which conservatives are allowed to speak
one of those areas is the area of sexual
orientation
here's what i mean the terms homosexual
and heterosexual
were once used exclusively as adjectives
to describe certain kinds of behavior
but the left i think has turned them
into nouns
now somebody can utter the sentence i am
a homosexual and nobody blinks twice
i believe this to be a purely
ideological phenomenon that was aided by
the medical community
i don't believe there is such a thing as
quote unquote being straight or being
gay
i just believe there are beneficial
preferences which are to be pursued
and harmful preferences which are to be
suppressed
this dichotomy can be seen in every
category of possible human desire such
as food clothes music etc but none of
these has anything to do with identity
my question is
do you think it's time conservatives
abandoned the idea that sexual
preference has anything to do with one's
identity at all
thanks love the show
yes really really excellent incisive
question and you're absolutely right
except a little bit at the end
because sexual preference can have
something to do with identity if you
make it your identity
just like race can have a whole lot to
do with your identity if you make it
your identity just like
i don't know some interest that you have
some hobby
you you work on model toy trains that
can be your identity if you make it your
identity but when you place your
identity in
small particular contingent sort of
often material things
then you're you're not going to be happy
you will not flourish
because our identity has to be grounded
in god in order for it to achieve its
fullest expression because we are
essentially
children of god we are made in the image
of god god is the essence of being he
says to moses at the burning bush
my name is i am who i am i i am i am
being
himself and so when we have our
our identity in i am who i am we know
who we are when we put our identity
anywhere else we don't know who we are
we're left with a sort of silly pathetic
question who who am i who am i i've got
to go find myself and that's certainly
it's certainly true now we're all
obsessed with the sexual identity stuff
but you're absolutely right when you say
these things you know in all categories
of human desire there are
better and worse things to pursue and so
you if you ground your identity in god
in an objective moral order that will
give you guidance to that and you won't
be left with you know like a like a 13
year old girl just saying like hey man
what am i you know i'm more of a black
metal punk visco kind of you know
pan-sexual whatever you know i don't
know i don't know how the kids talk
these days but you you won't be left
with that kind of silly shallow
understanding of identity you'll you'll
know who you are you'll have grown up
one time i heard uh i was mentioning to
a friend of mine that uh cons a
conservative friend of ours
used all these stupid political monikers
it's the right-wing version of gender
pronouns you know i am a minoricistic
libertarian anarcho traditional
syndicalist or whatever other stuff and
my friend just he sighed he said oh just
grow up
just grow up enough with all the stupid
identity markers okay next question
hey michael james here i just saw a
pragerupol that asks who you would save
your dog or a stranger
sixty percent of the thirty thousand
respondents said they would save their
dog
is there a single greater indicator of a
sick and dying society thanks bye
that's a pretty good one you're right
and why the reason they would save their
dogs by the way is not even because they
just necessarily hate people
it's not it's because they think their
dogs are their kids people no longer
treat dogs as dogs they treat dogs as
kids because people don't really have
kids anymore
and people are not even comfortable not
having kids and they often don't have
the strength and confidence and
encouragement to pursue that life which
can be very difficult because they're
not they're not
grounding their their identity and
anything beyond just sort of fleeting
pleasure and
an eternal present
so
yeah they just
they would save their dogs over the
drowning person because their dog to
them is their kid
but they don't realize the dog is a dog
okay and
it's a sick society that thinks that
dogs are kids okay one one question that
is written before we get into the member
black we had a lot of fun stuff in the
member block today we've got kirk
cameron stopping by we've got more mail
i like to do the extended mail bag in
the member block because i only get to
one old school
written out question uh with all the
voicemail bags so we'll get to that in
the member block too before we get to
that though from abby michael been
marinating on your discussion about
dating apps last week regarding kaylee
mcinerney's sister launching and dating
out for conservatives it's a good start
but we need to stop treating singles
like little islands
i suggest we i suggest we take it a step
further and launch the yenta app fiddler
on the roof where families do their job
and connect loved ones we as individuals
are not the best at understanding what
we need comprehensively we need family
input to get 360. bring family back into
dating thoughts love the show yeah i
think it's good to have family and close
friends
be involved in this kind of thing
there was that story that just came out
about
how
young people aren't having drinks on
their first dates anymore and one of the
explanations for this is that they don't
want to get date raped they don't want
the the
random stranger that they're meeting up
with to slip them a mickey and drag them
home and now they're all of these
completely
misaligned expectations of what it means
to go on a first date and what are you
going to do after the first date or the
second day or the third date and so now
people are so on guard that they go and
what should be a nice little love affair
you know you meet and you enjoy
someone's company now you're on guard
because you don't want them to rape you
because you're meeting a stranger so
yeah part of the explanation for that is
because we have no idea who these people
are now because we're just swiping them
like commodities on our on our phones on
our little portals to hell instead of a
situation where you say oh yeah john
yeah john was roommates with billy and
billy is my sister's boyfriend and so we
know we know all these people for many
years oh it's my cousin's co-worker
who's known for this and when you have a
much more
tightly knit social group you have much
more trust in people and so it makes the
dates go better it also makes society
function a lot better as well okay the
rest of the show is continuing right now
and you don't want to miss it so if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]
you